[Music]
I'm not trying to justify our decisions
but we did make that decision and and
and I say it all the time you know we
left Plano and let the United States and
went to Europe and [ __ ] I wanted to win
yeah I wanted to be the best and I knew
I needed a knife do you think that you
wouldn't have won as much as you had if
you hadn't taken the enhancements who
knows what would happen I mean I like to
think that I would have been the results
would have been the same there are other
people that would have said no that
would have been different I mean again
the sport is not that simple it's a
complicated sport there's a lot of luck
a lot of tactics a lot of stress it's
just the amazing thing is after
testicular cancer if you hadn't gone
back into racing you never would been
caught I'll raise you one go ahead
because you're right and then I had a
career from after cancer so from 98
until 2005 and then I came back in 2008
had I just stopped in 2005 it would have
been over that's it yeah so the come
back from Oh 8 or 9 and 10 and part of
11 was that bridge to the past